vous avez un lien d'emploi avec un
employeur si vous ne faites pas ce
pourquoi vous êtes payé l'employeur est
légitime de mettre fin à votre relation
d'emploi alors c'est exactement la même
situation si l'employeur qui sont les
électeurs du comté de la fontaine ou de
n'importe quelle autre circonscription
au Québec décide que l'employé ne fait
pas son travail c'est-à-dire l'élu ne
fait pas son travail on dit vous devriez
avoir la possibilité de mettre fin au
lien d'emploi c'est à dire de le
révoquer
c'était en 2011
ericare alors député de l'opposition est
indépendant promettait de déposer un
projet de loi pour permettre aux
électeurs de destituer leur députés en
cas de promesses brisée 12 ans plus tard
c'est le Parti québécois qui prend le
relais qui prend cette idée dans la
foulée du recul de la CAQ sur le
troisième lien il faut dire que Ricard
avait mis son siège en jeu son troisième
lieu autoroutier n'était pas réalisé je
m’entretiens dans un instant avec Eric
Duhem qui a lancé une pétition mais
aussi maintenant Paul Saint-Pierre
Plamondon chef du Parti québécois
bonsoir Monsieur Saint-Pierre permondon
bonsoir alors prenez le relais donc
d'Erica pourquoi viser ericaire parce
que c'est en 2011 les raisons il y a
plusieurs personnes qui applaudissent à
la fin du projet du troisième lien là
pour des raisons environnementales
économiques et autres mais pourquoi
viser uniquement
ericaire en fait j'ai pas du tout visé
Ricard donc je n'ai pas demandé
spécifiquement sa démission
contrairement aux parties conservateurs
qui s'exprima tout de suite après on
comprendra que ces récap démissionne ça
déclenche une partielle donc toutes
sortes de considérations politiques
autour de ça nous notre intervention
aujourd'hui c'est de demander à François
Legault de s'adresser à la population
parce que vraisemblablement la CAC aura
fait deux élections
en premier temps dur comme faire un
troisième nid qui ne tenait à presque
rien de sérieux donc le premier ministre
savait où devait savoir que ce projet-là
ne verrait jamais le jour mais pourtant
il le fait campagne là-dessus parce que
c'était payant électoralement et ce
faisant moi je pense qu'il doit traiter
les gens comme la marchandise électorale
il doit s'adresser à la population puis
deuxième chose nous allons déposer un
projet de loi qui donne à la population
un levier lorsque il y a un brie de
confiance où il y a vraiment un
manquement un engagement solonel c'était
une proposition que j'avais faite lors
de la course à la chefferie du Parti
québécois en 2020 donc en même temps
vous demandez à monsieur Legault
s'adresser à la population on a appris
au cours des derniers jours en tout cas
qu'il ne s'était même pas adressé à son
caucus on rapporte même qu'un ministre
je crois que c'est Monsieur Julien il
l'a appris dans les médias
donc demain ça va chauffer à la câble
derrière le porte-cléose il va
rencontrer son cocus après coup alors
est-ce que ça je le donne guillemets
est-ce que ça discute un peu monsieur
care de pas tenir sa promesse de mettre
son siège en jeu c'est parce que si on
parle seulement d'Éric car on passe à
côté du sujet le sujet c'est qu'il y a
plus d'une dizaine de députés puis un
chef de partie qui ont fait deux fois
campagne sur quelque chose qu'il savait
ne tenait pas la route puis n'aurait
jamais lieu et si c'était que ce
sujet-là mais on voit la même chose sur
la langue française la dernière campagne
c'était à quel point la loi 96 est
extraordinaire trois quatre semaines
après la campagne le discours changeait
complètement ils ont fait cela avec les
seuils d'immigration en parlant en
utilisant des mots avec lesquels je suis
pas d'accord comme le mot suicidaire
mais ensuite il faut exactement
l'inverse on interprète 70 000 prenez
aujourd'hui l'annonce de la ministre
guilbo qui dit pour le RAM de l'Est
c'est dans ma circonscription mais on
aura un projet final quelque part en
2026 donc en d'autres mots à nouveau la
CAC aura fait deux élections en parlant
du REM de l'Est comme le un projet
signature de la CAQ qu'est-ce qu'il
restera au bout de 8 ans rien d'accord
donc maintenant il faut fixer une limite
à ça et une proposition on s'inspire de
la Californie de la Colombie-Britannique
avec quelle mécanisme ça marcherait
comment bon on va se donner quelques
semaines justement pour comparer ce qui
se fait partout dans le monde parce que
quand même pas un mécanisme si
exceptionnel que ça mais essentiellement
lorsque une masse critique de gens sont
prêtes à demander la révocation d'un
député parce qu'ils ont le sentiment de
cette fée flouée de cette fait
lorsqu'il y a un bride de confiance
essentiellement assez important pour que
les gens se déplacent et qui a une masse
critique il y aurait la possibilité pour
la population de révoquer le député il
faut le faire intelligemment parce que
si on met le seuil trop bas ça crée de
l'instabilité ça peut être prise en
étage mais donc il faut bien travailler
on va regarder notamment le cas de la
Californie
mais on le fait d'une part parce que
c'est ironiquement le projet d'ericaire
en 2011 mais également parce que
c'était monsieur le groupe voudriez
destituer c'est lui qui a brisé la
promesse vous dites on vise pas ericaire
mais c'est Monsieur Lebeau je veux
donner à la population ou Madame la
chambre de prendre ses décisions là
dépendamment de comment être perçoivent
chacun des enjeux mais je pense que ce
serait simple le Premier ministre ne se
contente pas d'envoyer des ministres ou
des gens s'excuser et qu'il nous
explique pourquoi il a mené deux
campagnes sur un enjeu qui le qualifiait
de nécessaire de faire ça allait se
faire alors que maintenant qu'on
comprend la chronologie du manque
d'études ou du peu de sérieux de cette
démarche-là sur le sur la carte en fait
en 2022 notre projet au Parti québécois
était plus fouillé et plus mieux
recherché que ce que le gouvernement
avait fait avec les moyens de l'État
avec le ministère qui peut travailler et
d'ailleurs la CAQ semble vouloir
reprendre notre
proposition encore faut-il pouvoir se
fier à leur nouvelle engagement
qu'est-ce que ça vaut
est-ce qu'on peut croire une promesse de
la CAQ c'est la question que plusieurs
les gens se posent le projet de Monsieur
care c'est 50%
la pétition je parlais monsieur 50 %,
est-ce que c'est un seuil démocratique
en guillemets
on va regarder parce que c'est peu
probable que 50% de la population swing
quelque chose ce geste là donc c'est
pour ça que c'est important avant de
déposer le projet de loi de regarder ce
qui fonctionne le mieux d'accord dans le
monde parce qu'il faut quand même agir
avec doigté pour pas que ce soit
nuisible mais que ça crée une discipline
à savoir que lorsqu'on est candidat pour
un parti on est en tête qu'on peut pas
dire absolument n'importe quoi que la
population comme un certain levier une
certaine pomme si vous me passez
l'expression vis-à-vis de n'importe quoi
merci beaucoup monsieur j'ai perdu au
revoir
sa parole vaut rien c'est pas compliqué
c'est ça c'est le sentiment général que
les gens de Québec ont présentement si
le gars il met son siège en jeu si le
gars dit qu'il y a aucune excuse
possible pour qu'il recule sur le
troisième mien ça après ça il sort puis
il se met à appuyé le troisième mien
quel crédibilité lui reste si François
Le gouttolaire un gars qui a aussi peu
de parole dans son focus en dit long
alors c'est le chef du Parti
conservateur arrive du M aujourd'hui qui
se trouvait devant le bureau de côté
j'étais petit ministre ericaire il a
ensuite fait du porte-à-porte en même
temps les citoyen de la circonscription
a signé une pétition pour être la mise à
démission tout devrait se passer dans ce
côté-là jusqu'à maintenant c'est ce que
je crois comprendre
alors vous contrairement monsieur
Saint-Pierre de mon nom vous visez
ericaire mais je pense que
Erica se vise lui-même le spa moi qui a
inventé le projet de loi 493 qui le
déposé en vue de destituer un député
c'est pas moi qui a mis mon siège en jeu
c'est pas moi qui a dit que s'il y avait
pas de troisième lien de réaliser il
allait il allait démissionner puis sous
aucune excuse il pourrait reculer ou ne
pas démissionner c'est pas moi qui ai
dit que j'irai jusqu'au bout de mon sang
pour que le troisième bien soit réalisé
sans quoi je m'en vais donc je pense que
Monsieur car il s'est lui-même mis dans
une cage puis aujourd'hui mais il faut
qu'il vise avec les conséquences de ses
actes et de ce qui le premier à la
population de Québec mais ce n'est pas
victime de la promesse du gouvernement
qui était petit on a vu monsieur le bois
pour consulter personne avant de tirer
en fin de mettre fin au projet mais
c'est c'est Monsieur cas lui-même que
choisit de déposer un projet de loi il
était même pas la CAQ à ce moment-là
c'est lui-même qui pense qu'une pétition
peut le destituer c'est lui-même qui a
mis son siège en jeu à deux élections en
passant pas juste la dernière mais même
l'autre avant aussi je dis c'est lui qui
a fait ça qui a choisi encore récemment
il disait qu'il était y aller jusqu'au
bout de son sein mais là il y a plus de
bon sang là donc il faut qu'il faut
qu'il donne la il faut qu'il donne ce
qui est ce qu'il a promis ce qui ne
l'empêcherait pas soit du temps passant
de se représenter à sa propre succession
vous savez comme moi que shinakups il y
a presque quoi
ce matin avait fait la même chose avec
Jean-Chrétien
Ottawa l'avait ensuite au fait qu'elle
avait pas respecté son engagement elle
avait démissionné c'était même
représenté à sa propre succession il
pourrait se représenter mais il a besoin
d'une légitimité démocratique parce
qu'il a menti à la population et
entraînement parce qu'évidemment vous
seriez candidat contre lui à ce
moment-là
conduit parce que vous compreniez le
madame saut là les candidats
conservateurs comme la population de
Québec l'ont sans flouer on a été roulé
dans la farine et on a élu des gens sous
fausses représentation le 3 octobre
dernier des gens qui ont dit le
contraire de ce qu'ils allaient faire et
il y a des députés où il y a des députés
aujourd'hui je leur ai parlé ils me
l'ont dit en fait
j'ai parlé aussi à certains qui m'ont
avoué que si cette conférence de presse
là avait eu lieu il y a 7 ou 8 mois ces
gens-là seraient pas députés qu'on
aurait des conservateurs aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale il faut bien
comprendre que ça ait un impact majeur
ça a été la promesse phare de la
coalition Québec ça a été comme disait
Bernard drinville dans un débat la
question de l'urne disait je cite qu'on
a besoin d'une majorité forte pour faire
le troisième lien alors qu'aujourd'hui
il recule qu'on soit pas ou contre le
troisième lien ça part à part c'est le
fait que c'est là c'est la promesse
qu'ils ont fait puis ils ont été élus
sous force représentation
vous vous visez le 50 % plus simple une
pétition qui deviendrait symbolique au
fond pour mettre la pression
probablement insoutenable sur
Erika on a repris textuellement ce que
Monsieur car proposait dans son projet
de loi 493 donc effectivement de toutes
les dispositions qu'il proposait on les
a mis en application incluant le 50%
plus 1 on a aussi et en fait il y a deux
petites
on veut on veut s'assurer que on
respecte il pourra pas dire que c'est
parce qu'on sait pas exactement son
projet de loi donc on a fait exactement
la seule différence qui est ministre la
de la numérisation donc je pense qu'il
va comprendre il y a 11 ans les
signatures électroniques on les
acceptait pas maintenant même
l'Assemblée nationale reconnaît les
signatures électroniques donc pour cette
pétition on reconnaît les signatures
électroniques les gens peuvent aller à
cadre démissionne.com ils peuvent
ajouter leur nom de la circonscription
seulement oui la circonscription de
l'appelerie
le parti conservatoire
c'est presque c'est presque 30 000
signatures
1547 signatures madame sot monsieur
carot 19000 votes à l'élection donc à
partir du moment où on va voir 19000
signatures je peux vous dire que déjà on
va dire qu'ils ont le même nombre de
signatures que Monsieur car a eu de vote
donc je pense qu'on commence à avoir une
certaine légitimité on rentre dans un
autre légitime et on va se rendre
jusqu'à 30 000 on l'espère mais on
lâchera pas aller au cours des deux
prochains mois on va envoyer des
dépliants à toutes les portes on a déjà
des équipes aujourd'hui on a commencé
notre opération de porte-à-porte on va
la faire pendant deux mois parce que
dans le projet de loi ça disait qu'on
avait 60 jours pour atteindre le 50 + 1
on va également mettre des affiches dans
la circonscription on va faire des
téléphones toutes une opérations de se
faire
qu'est-ce que vous aviez comme cause à
défendre on va promouvoir mais madame
Dussault ça nous donne une source mais
ça nous a étouffé aussi le 3 octobre
n'oubliez pas que on serait peut-être
débuter à l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui je parlerai comme chef de
partie élu ça nous a tout fait à
l'époque puis maintenant que leur limace
sont tombés et que la vérité sort et que
la claque le recul ben ça oui on a du
souffle elle va déposer une question
dans d'autres circonscriptions dans la
salle de Bernard drinville par exemple
une martine Biron qui ont fait aussi
campagne là-dessus puis dans les
circonscriptions où il y avait une plus
petite majorité
il y a des circonscriptions de base donc
parler oui on veut on veut partir ça
dans la circonscription de la pétrie
pour les raisons que je vous ai
mentionné je pense que demain il va
avoir une réunion du caucus comme vous
savez des députés de la CAQ de la grande
région de Québec avec le Premier
ministre on s'attend ce que monsieur
Legault s'excuse on va voir combien de
députés sont prêts à obéir à leur chef
ou des combien députés vont se tenir
avec la population qui les aillent je
pense que c'est une décision très
difficile pour plusieurs députés
présentement mais les électeurs vont
s'en souvenir parce que la cave vous
savez ça a été un parti de Québec
historiquement c'était la base de
fondamentale aujourd'hui que ce parti-là
tente de plaire à un électorat dans
région de Montréal puis comment il
abandonne la région de Québec c'est
assez dramatique c'est un gros
changement politique étant de s'opérer
madame
bonsoir un plaisir au revoir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI